okay in that case
i just want to say a lot of what you
talked about also reflects
in the field of mimetics when it comes
to
you mentioned how linguistics was
taxonomical at first was just
categorizing things
and the same is true when it comes to
the field of biology
until you get the universal theory right
darwin's evolution
i just think that for linguistics you've
found the genetics of linguistics that
is to say the mechanisms that underlie
linguistic patterns
through language instinct and etc but i
still think that the software the words
we choose
follow evolutionary and memetic
algorithms
to differentiate it from change to
differentiate it from change
in order for something to evolve it has
to be hereditable
meaning can be passed down from one
generation to the next we're not talking
genetic irritability
people don't intrinsically know spanish
or what have you
not beyond maybe a language instinct
that's universal all languages but has
to be heritable
has to vary from one generation to the
next
so you have to have mutations of it
different states different iterations
and then lastly it has to be selected
for
or against and by that we don't mean by
some higher power
we mean it's increasing or decreasing
in its use and to me words
memes behaviors follow these
evolutionary
conditions and therefore evolve
are organic do you do go ahead
i think it's clearer if we drop the word
evolve
which means something in biology and use
the word change
there's a lot of detailed study and
investigation
of how languages change a lot of
research into that that's got
many results but it doesn't use these
analogies and speculations don't really
contribute to it
the critical difference between
evolution and change is that it's
iterative
from generation to the next that it can
be passed
that's not the difference the difference
be between evolution and change
has to do with whether your genome
changes